alors ça veut dire dans le cas de la
sphère des de ses tweets sur des ch
elle avait posté trois photos de dèche
je le disais que c'était en réponse à un
parallèle qui a été fait entre le front
national à l'époque aujourd'hui
rassemblement national et des ch
en tout cas cela lui a valu d'être mise
en examen est aujourd'hui donc une
expertise psychiatrique a été demandée
par un juge
marine le pen s'empresse de dire que
c'est un scandale
écoutez ce qu'elle déclarait ce matin
c'est très grave et je ne vous cache pas
que je commence à trouver ce régime un
peu inquiétant tout de même je n'irai
pas bien entendu me soumettre à cette
expertise psychiatrique et j'attends de
voir comment le magistrat entend m'y
contraindre
cette expertise richard buck c'est un
cadeau servi sur un plateau à marie le
pen d'abord c'est quelque chose qui est
prévu c'est pas une exception à la l'air
de dire marine le pen qu'on fait un
régime d'exception la concernant faut
savoir que cette expertise
elle est prévue dans le cadre de ce
travail de la justice donc voilà après
il est possible de ne pas être si vous
voulez bien pour que nos internautes
tous ceux qui sont pas tout à fait au
fait de la question effectivement dans
le cadre de la mise en examen pour
diffusion d'image violente le code de
procédure pénale prévoit qu'une
expertise psychiatrique et de
diligentées sur la personne de ces la
loi est effectivement la faire pour être
au contraire être annulées au fond s'il
expertise n'était pas fait
après la rue qu un ce est prévu il n'y a
pas de régime d'exception pour marine le
pen donc pas besoin d'aller sur une
communication où tout d'un coup elle
joue une victime avec un régime
particulier qui lui seraient appliqués
deuxième chose c'est que sur cette
expertise elle peut être par moment à la
fois utile et même nécessaire
léthel dans le cas de marine le pen moi
j'ai envie de dire qu'elle assume aussi
c'est conséquences d'un point de vue
politique ce sera encore mieux que d'un
point de vue psychiatrique et d'un autre
côté
j'ajoute que elle peut ne pas s'y rendre
à cette lente et j'aï le gagner à quel
moment on va l'y contraint mais il est
possible de ne pas s'y rendre on
constate qu'elle ne s'y est pas rendu il
ya très peu de moyens de contrainte je
crois à y aller donc tous les arguments
qu'elle donne c'est une espèce de mise
en scène encore sur la victimisation
alors
il n'y a pas de régime d'exception pour
marine le pen ya le régime qui est
appliquée d'une manière générale dans le
cadre de ces mises en examen et voilà
moi je trouve que aller dans le rôle qui
est le sien d'or mais simplement ça
aurait pu trouver malgré tout une façon
de faire qui soit plus on va dire moins
voyantes et oui oui alors elle a
appliqué à la lettre les textes est là
elle avoue dérouler la procédure
moi j'avais deux trois choses à dire sur
sur sa réaction sur ce contexte la
première c'est que on oublie une
dimension ou dans ses tweets et la
publication de photos c'est que
effectivement il ya eu de la publication
de photos violentes et c'est au nom de
la protection des mineurs
sur twitter la règle de peine à des
enfants publié j'ai vu les photos elles
sont d'une violence extrême publier ces
photos quand on est un responsable
politique une élue en l'occurrence sur
twitter et ensuite prendre des airs
rentrer quand la justice d où une
procédure pour protéger justement les
mineurs c'est assez étonnant
je voudrais dire une deuxième chose qui
ne semble pas inintéressante on voit
aujourd'hui dans la vie politique
française et les réactions de mélenchon
à l' expertise psychiatrique sont dans
ce registre là où trash isation complète
permanente espèces ont parlé tout à
l'heure de transgression continue et qui
ne s'arrête jamais et à un moment donné
justement pour reprendre un peu de
figures psychanalytique la transgression
elle s'arrête quand la loi tombe et là
la loi est tombée très clairement et
elle est tombée elle lui demande la loi
d'aller se soumettre à une expertise
psychiatrique
je trouve que symboliquement c'est une
très bonne nouvelle que la justice est
appliqué à la lettre les textes je
trouve que symboliquement c'est une très
bonne nouvelle car refusent de s'y
soumettre parce qu'elle nous a déjà fait
le coup ne pas se rendre à des
convocations des juges n'ont d'autre à
faire je trouve que c'est parfait et
c'est un naufrage de communication un
naufrage politique qui se prépare
super intéressant on va voir ce qui va
se passer social manier et je sais bien
après les 2 millions de saisies de
financement
du front national aujourd'hui
rassemblement national ça fait un peu
acharnement c'est une citoyens c'est une
citoyenne comme les autres les subi
exactement aux mêmes règles que les
autres je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
tout ce que vous venez de dire ça c'est
totalement vrai et je suis aussi
d'accord avec vous sur le fait tout ça
nourrit sa machine à victimisation et
quel temps après je pense qu'une société
démocratique saine doit avoir tous les
partis représentés dont classe et il se
trouve que ça tombe l'un après l'autre
c'était déjà en cours avant les deux
millions qui leur sont tombés dessus
mais c'est encore une fois la triche et
elle paye enfin géré ça vaut pour tous
les français ça vaut aussi pour
l'instant de petit mois dans cette
histoire est une chose que je trouve
assez gras c'est la rapidité la
dextérité avec laquelle monsieur
mélenchon c'est ccd décidé d'en être le
grand défenseur des marine le pen
j'ai l'impression que ce n'est pas la
première fois et là il parle de
psychiatrisation de la politique
non mais ça suffit sa peine
effectivement pourquoi cette obligatoire
de soumettre quand vous diffuser ce
genre d'image de propagande c'est que
souvent ça touche des jeunes et que ce
n'est pas une interaction de voir s'ils
sont politisés s'ils sont radicalisées
ou s'ils ont juste dans un moment de
schizophrénie te dis mais alors qu'est
en train de faire jean luc mélenchon en
prenant si souvent à des français fait
maintenant on a l'exemple italien
moi j'ai toujours une peur de ces
extrêmes qu'il se faisait mutuellement
la danse du ventre
mais le fait qu'ils aillent et pour les
deux millions et là aujourd'hui avec
cette histoire là seul le premier a
twitté moi je trouve pour l'avenir ça ne
ça n'augure rien de bon marc lé pot de
suippes en dessous des lois donc si la
loi dit qu'elle doit être examinée
psychiatriquement il faut qu'elle le
soit question comment ce qui me surprend
c'est que la sphère du trad et du tout
des trois photos que les féminines c'est
2015 donc s'il ya trois ans et donc la
justice trois ans après dit on va
diligenter mais nous voulons c'est trop
une ride
entre temps elle a été au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle je dire que
potentiellement une femme qui est
dérangé psychologiquement chacun aura
son avis personnel sur l'état et d'
équilibre mental la règle en métal
démarrer mais en l'occurrence à l'étalé
au deuxième tour de l'épreuve
je vous rappelle qu'on a pu voir quelle
était quelque peu dérangé vous rappelez
quand elle faisait son effet
de danse on peut dire que peut-être
qu'effectivement il aurait fallu la
faire expertiser avant en tout cas je
trouve que la justice elle n'est pas
prête à prendre les décisions dans les
bons temps et que peut-être qu'on a mis
la france en danger on lui permettant
des candidates à l'élection
présidentielle si jamais elle devait
être empêché de leur rapport d'août aux
états unis il ya une pétition très large
pour trump pour l'état de 2 pts 6 capes
qui est je trouve ça pas mal intéressant
c'est justement introduction de la
psychologie de la psychiatrie dans la
vie politique alors qu'il y en a une
remarque intéressante je suis juste pour
vous dire ce que dit jean christophe
alquier le lot le vrai c'est le pseudo
de notre internaute
elle est la marine le pen accuse des
exécutifs de vouloir la faire taire elle
confond justice et exécutif c'est grave
c'est vrai parce que c'était peut-être
pas forcément dans l'extrait qu'on a
passé mais elle disait je m'inquiète
d'un pouvoir qui fait passer ses
opposants pour vous en gros ça a été
pensé alors c'est pas du tout le cas
elle fait le pouvoir n'a rien à voir
c'est la justice qui est indépendante
rappelons dans notre pays c'est juste
effectivement le temps qu'a pris cette
justice est scandaleux mais de toute
façon tout est bon pour l'opposition
d'aller chercheur qui a beaucoup de
trucs beaucoup plus légitime est
beaucoup plus complexe à aller chercher
dans la tête du gouvernement et chercher
des poux dans la tête du gouvernement
mais pas ça là elle est encore une fois
là c'est bientôt les élections
européennes elle espère bénéficier de la
vague populiste qui a partout en europe
sans rien faire donc elle se tient là il
n'y a rien de mieux pour le front
national depuis son père que cette
posture de crucifier le pouvoir ne veut
pas demain ils m'empêchent de m'exprimer
venez à moi vous citoyen qui est trompé
par ce pouvoir qui veut me faire passer
pour folle et encore une fois ce n'est
pas le cas personne veut la faire passer
pour folle
est ce que on l'a noté il ya eu fréjus
le congrès où je sais pas le terme exact
du rassemblement social week-end dernier
ils reprennent du poil de la bête au vu
des sondages aussi qu'est ce que vous en
dites jamais cessé ça participe aussi de
cette remobilisation et de mes week moi
je crois qu'en fait elles adressent des
messages qui sont à la fois des messages
à son propre électorat et là bon elle
al'annonce des messages qui vont avec ce
qui pourrait douter justement après ces
quelques années à la fois l'échec patent
à l'élection présidentielle le fait
qu'aux législatives
ce parti n'a pas fait le score et le
nombre de députés qu'il attendait donc
il ya eu une crise il ya eu un doute les
départs de filippo et c'est ce parti à
inquiéter une partie de son électorat et
l'essai avec effectivement des éléments
qui sont des éléments de communication
pour tevez mais il se réjouira l'elorn
europe elle mais bien évidemment c'est
son visage elle voit elle voit des
perspectives d'un rebond beaucoup plus
rapide que ce qu'elle imaginait elle
s'est même interrogé je crois est le
même pour savoir si elles restaient dans
la course ou si elle se retirait
finalement ailier elle voit des ressorts
je voulais juste marqué la petite
différence entre le débat qu'on a sur
mon groupe 6 4 il est personne est ce
qu'on a eues la semaine dernière où il y
avait notamment de françoise degois une
interpellation en disant attention sur
tout ce qui est psychiatre isation et en
étant en train de dire qu'il fallait pas
qu'on dérives trop vers ce sujet on
était notamment avec la lettre anonyme
qui avaient été adressés s'agissant
trump et qui mettait en exergue le fait
que ce président avait probablement un
problème mental
voilà pour dire qu'on a quand même des
avions à très partagés soir sous les
atours d'une semaine à leur triomphe aux
sommes versées alors il va vous êtes
deux tiers d'entre vous estiment qu'elle
a raison de refuser les expertises
psychiatriques c'est le résultat à notre
question twitter elle est avocate aussi
je le rappelle juste pour mémoire le pen
voilà dans le joue moins sur sa joie
qu'elle soit que ce soit eux existent
aussi en si bonne forme que ça ne fasse
que si on prend le sondage de la semaine
dernière sur les élections européennes
elle est deuxième à l'est à 20%
la vraie affaire sans bienvenue en étant
assez près nul mais c'est oui c'est peu
c'est peu pour une élection est arrivé
en tête il ya cinq ans vous aidera de
voir une élection ou que la province
elle est très forte elle est arrivé
numéro un où elle avait dépassé les 30%
donc en début de campagne je la trouve
très affaibli et peut-être effectivement
que sa stratégie de victimisation c'est
fait aussi pour essayer de rebondir
faire parler d'autre chose que de ses
piètres raser ma fille est trop et puis
même en terme de grands thermes de en
termes d'idées j'ai entendu rien ay ay
surya quelques alliés en europe
oui enfin il bouscule pas non plus pour
ce n'est pas pour faire des scènes
filmées comme une partie de la
population avec elle veut dire en europe
ils font très bien leur leur chemin sans
elle salvini d'ailleurs a appris un peu
faim c'est pas français distance là il
ne veut que les gagnants et maintenant
qui la roumanie la plupart des autres
alors on va reparler aussi des retraites
des retraités sont transition d'une sans
offrir des transitions vous connaissez
marquer